my god I'm huge now what happened a four
inches on my headphone port I'm serious
wait where's my oh oh thank god this is
a story about a new iPhone the three
hundred and ninety nine dollar iPhone se
you see in 2018 Apple discontinued the
first generation iPhone se but in 2020
while the world was on lockdown because
of rotavirus the rotavirus coronavirus
Apple released a new model that was
really just a repurposed iPhone 8 with
an iPhone 11 processor and basically an
iPhone 10 our camera and I your humble
narrator had gone so crazy stuck at home
that well so I'm basically made of old
parts I'm a Franken phone and while the
iPhone se sees 4.7 inch screen was now
much bigger than its old self it was
much smaller than its current much more
expensive iPhone siblings not even a
phone you're a tablet at least I fit in
the pocket Who am I kidding
who's gonna want me compared to those
fancy big guys over there little did the
iPhone se know that for 399 dollars a
lot of people would find him to be one
of Apple's best values in years wait
really compared to its older kin the
iPhone 6 7 & 8 the iPhone se with it's a
13 Bionic processor found itself quite
capable now I'm doing game graphics
oh no issue the SC's new processor also
meant many more years of iOS software
updates as the iPhone 6s and the older
se neared the end of their life cycles
oh goodie I just hope those updates
don't slow me down
what would soon become known to the
iPhone se is that with a new processor
it could take beautiful shots even in
portrait mode that was previously only
available on those more expensive phones
coming for you I just blurt out the one
part and left the important part clear
in some portrait shots the S II didn't
even bet
in the $999 iPhone 11 Pro at blurring
around the edges the SE could take
portrait shots with its front facing
camera - look at that smooth 4k footage
I feel like I'm standing in front of all
the TVs at target browser hey hey hey
hey hey buddy hey buddy stop hey hey
buddy hey buddy please
unlike the higher-end pro models the
iPhone se is only capable of portrait
photos on humans no person detected come
on it's five o'clock somewhere according
to my fabulous world clock
unfortunately the iPhone se didn't have
the endurance of its bigger iPhone
siblings it struggled to make it to the
end of the workday without getting into
the red low battery territory luckily
the iPhone se supported wireless
charging and fast charging if you had
the right adapters it still only came
with a dinky five watt charger in its
box as the iPhone se finished its review
it finally felt confident at 399 it was
gonna be a great phone for many people
who'd resisted the bigger bulkier very
expensive new iPhones so what if nothing
about me is new I've still got my
beloved home button which you can't get
on any other iPhone now and that was the
story of the iPhone se the end come on
don't you wanna hang out or something I
got a got Mean Girls on DVD